the economic crisis has hit Ichi dong
hard for months he's been checking the
offerings at a job placement service in
Shenzhen at age 52 he belongs to the
first generation of China's migrant
workers he came from the impoverished
countryside to earn a living for his
family China became the world's
workbench and he worked hard in the
factories of course it affects me just
look at the posters they're all looking
to hire someone between the ages of 20
and 40 it's very tough for us older
people in China's industrial heart the
Pearl River Delta factories are closing
and companies are declaring bankruptcy
cheap mass production is the key to
success now china wants to turn into a
modern innovative industrial nation but
the transition is difficult and painful
and there's no guaranteed outcome
especially for workers like Ichi dong
who can't keep up with the new
technologies the surviving factories are
being modernized and they need personnel
with better training we drove to the
neighboring metropolis gwangju it used
to be easy to earn money here but now
many companies have trouble making ends
meet
rent and other expenses have mushroomed
in recent years Lindau originally from
Hong Kong manufactures clothing in
Guangzhou
she says profits have shrunk drastically
some migrant workers have returned to
the countryside because they can no
longer afford to live in Guangzhou so
there's a lack of low-cost labor and the
young people who are better educated
don't want to take menial jobs to top it
off international competition is
increasing because the course is a
climbing up to climbing up that means
some people will the customer will move
to other country because other country
is more lower than the China window we
can not competition with Vietnam
Cambodia India we drive back to Shenzhen
within a few decades it grew from a
village to a city of millions a symbol
of China's economic miracle but will the
glory days return Deng Xiaoping opened
up China's economy more than 30 years
ago posters still exhort people to
follow the Communist Party the new
five-year plan projects 10 million new
jobs no mass layoffs and a growth rate
of 6.5%
Moochie dong says life is hard but he
and his wife are a lot better off now
than back then he's worked all his life
so his two sons could get a good
education they now have jobs and provide
some help for you and his wife but who
is in certain of what China's economic
future holds at the moment it's hard to
say there's a lot of talk about how
people should sound startups become more
innovative but innovations take time so
we may have a rocky road ahead of us for
a while whose granddaughter comes home
from school and who has received good
news a job offer to deliver goods for a
factory it's not much but it's a ray of
hope
you